the TSA is launching new technology that
could change the way bags are scanned at
airports across the country the goal is
to replace aging x-ray scanners with new
3d carry-on bag scanners that used the
same technology as cat scans the TSA
believes they will spot explosives older
machines could miss Kris Van Cleave is
at New York's JFK International Airport
ahead of the technologies official debut
tomorrow Chris good morning good morning
this is the scanner here at JFK and it's
coming online at a time when there still
is real concern about the potential of
some explosives that may get past some
types of older x-ray machines that's
part of why the TSA is asking people to
take liquids food devices larger than a
cell phone even powders out of their
bags but the TSA believes this machine
could change all of that for pliers this
brand-new 3d CT scanner at the American
Airlines terminal at New York's JFK
Airport can see through just about
anything in a carry-on bag to spot a
potential threat here's what a TSA
screener sees now from the current
generation x-ray machines look closely
can you spot the knife and now that's
why it's yes they ask you to remove your
laptop for this reason but using your
finger just manipulate it around
wow that's the view from the new
analogic scanner going into JFK the
manufacturer gave us a first look last
year they work like a CT machine in a
hospital seeing through even a cluttered
bag and gives screeners the ability to
zoom in and rotate the bag for a 360
degree view american airlines donated 8
of the roughly 300 thousand dollar
scanners to TSA including the one at JFK
we think in perhaps five years or so the
passengers won't have to take anything
out of the carry-on bags TSA
administrator David pukowski calls the
technology revolutionary what the
capable are doing is detecting a wider
range of explosives which is very
important and then a much lower weight
of explosives they're just much better
at detection so you really get you get
better security faster essentially the
TSA plans to have 15 deployed to these
airports by the end of the year and are
authorized to by up to 240 in 2019
they'll need about 2,000 to cover
Airport checkpoint in the country Jose
free Giz American Airlines head of
security just getting to that point that
an anon pre-check Lane you're able to
keep your liquids gels era cells and
laptops and no electronics in your bags
it's it's a new era if you will and
we're really excited about it the TSA
has tested this technology at airports
in Phoenix in Boston and found it does
speed up the lines because there are
fewer secondary bag searches Congress is
pushing TSA to get this technology out
there as fast as possible but
realistically to replace every x-ray
machine at every airport in the u.s. is
going to take years Gail yeah thank you
Chris but I'm excited about that machine
thank you very much just the other day I
had a bottle of water in the bag and I I
removed it so they take it too and then
they go would you like to go back out
and drink the water and come back at no
I would not but wouldn't it be great you
don't have to do I know take out the
water bottle well maybe they could just
do it at least in the busiest airport
yes New York Atlanta LA but if you're
first you go yeah faster and safer yeah
I like this I like this a lot a lot a
lot